hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night my
name is markiplier and we are venturing
down in the depths of some dungeon or
other or something like that okay
doesn't know ah well my favorite my ding
dong favorite with rats running all over
the place okay one of the prisoners got
free installed two of my keys one is for
the prison door and the other to the
Bulls room the prisoner was hoping the
keys could open the way back upstairs to
get out of here but either way there's
no escape from this place the prisoner
was found but only with the prison key
with him I haven't found the key to the
ball room yet but it has to be closed
because he couldn't get past the
catacombs door that led to the upstairs
floor the upper floors I'll use him as
an example to scare some other prisoners
that even think about escaping this
prison first I made him swallow the
prison door key and then I locked him
inside the ball and I told him the next
time I need the key I will burn it out
of him that should be enough to scare
the other prisoners wait why would why
would there be a next time it sounds
like you made him it sounds like you
killed him pretty much and I have the
Bulls key why do I have that okay
alright anyway I'm curious about is this
supposed chest here it says something
about growing hitting it with something
but I'm trying to hit it with these
giant mallets but let's see here if
these don't do it then I'm guessing it
ain't gonna work yeah anyway let me go
look for something else in the bowls
room
I don't know where the Bulls room is but
I'll find it eventually not that those
monsters are gone anyway Oh what ha ha
well that was difficult
all right here we go so he locked him
inside the bull hello
oh holy crap
hi why are your legs like that
ok sorry buddy
I gotta get a key here oh come on don't
be like this
Oh what come on it's not opening yeah I
don't think it's just I'm I don't think
it's just funky controls I think this
literally is not opening ok um know what
I know there's a key in there but I just
have to get to it oh shut up
I'll stop being such a baby don't know
why I don't set them free I could use
some help here kind of all alone and
whatnot but it doesn't matter for I am a
rock
yeah okay that's where I came in
okay there's gotta be a way to get out
there's gotta be right huh maybe I need
to hit it with something given with you
boxes smash it over the head cuz that
seems to do everything I wanted to
there's nothing in there anyway just go
without a little light here for a little
bit
shut up walk one potato two potato three
potato four
I didn't work yeah I don't know what the
deal is but what's going on here it's
just not moving at all ah I literally
cannot oh oh
oh I just killed him
whoops oh sorry sorry
I just murdered that guy okey-dokey
well anyway so now maybe is key can get
to yer no this is still just broken man
I swear the chest is stuck I need to
find something to hit it with I thought
that the giant mallet would have been
good but maybe I need to find a rock
because that always did it before let me
use this helmet thing nope
okay this is another mallet wonk wonk I
swear gah ah nope
oh I can see it in there but no do I
need to hit it with mmm what about this
can I use this no I cannot what about
one of these body parts be lovely
wouldn't it yeah shut up you'll care
about me don't care about anything I do
I see you rocks just not working roll it
ah what oh come on don't be like that
what all the game crashed ah okay
alright I'll be right back guys be back
in a second and we're back so we got the
key here ding dong ding dong and now
I just had to watch that guy dog and of
course cuz I was lovely now I need to
find something to with which to hit that
dang chest you'd think you would think
you really think that a giant hammer
would work but it don't so I got a move
on with my life
catch all-new gel nope ok alright anyway
whatever it's fine I'll figure out how
to use the prison key and then I'll get
back to that when I need to because I
think there's a piece of an orb there
that goes to the ladies on the other
side of the hall whoa where where
where destruction is he coming from I
want to know which way to run
we'll go this way
ha that was wrong that was the wrong
choice ok maybe I can just go around I'm
depending on which direction he goes I'm
burning through oil way too much good oh
he was coming out this way ok I'll just
go around should be fine I should be
able to get by I'm pretty easily
okay good good good good don't look at
him just me and her my way through
up not looking at you totally sneaky Oh
stealth level 99 awesome oh yeah this
okay here we go
click click ah bang bang ding dong was
that really my father
let's get out of here and get into the
castle I thought I was in the castle man
I get a feeling that this is gonna be a
very long and very involved let's play
here so and I'm happy oh oh not happy
about that not happy about those
mannequins Cher Oh
Oh aah why Oh
anything else gonna pop out at me if
this sounds like a bad place locked in
their lock to just magical floating fire
huh Oh lose nothing in there I saw aah
come on
oh crap aah Oh that's what the magical
floating fire was was a monster Oh go
away
Oh going aah
big oil I don't know how I got here all
that remember is that when I went to
sleep and by the time I woke up I was in
this prison can it be a dream I know
this isn't a dream I now know that this
isn't a dream it's more like a living
nightmare
I hear screams all night long and
they've been doing some really painful
tests on me I just want my kids and wife
back please God why have you done this
to me
I stole a hammer from the storage and
one to the catacombs and one of the
other prisoners have got his hands on
two keys some luck
we may be getting the hell out of here
but I don't even know where I am all I
know is that this place is really dark
the prisoner that stole the keys was
found out and now all my hope is lost
I'm just gonna try and get out with a
fight the next thing that comes in here
is going to get this hammer in their
heads so God so help me God
ok so did you get it
Hey look a hammer you did not get it you
failed
Oh where do I go no I do what I do
hallo Luis unlike I would have tried to
climb out that way
I hear monster but there's no monster
music oh oh why oh come on
I don't remember can the things in
penumbra bash down doors I think it was
doesn't sound like something from number
then again this is on fire so I'm
guessing holes up in the air alright
maybe I just got a run past it I don't
see any other way here we go
[ __ ] off get ready good [ __ ] you why was
this dude where's this go
is that [ __ ] thing okay I know
aha
huh what happened to that thing
oh okay all right okay I'm guessing I
need a ladder piece the ladder is broken
I need to find a way to fix it okay
all right well that's something small
drill some test tubes pieces of bread I
don't know I was dragged from my world
and put in this cell but I still don't
know where I am all that I know is I'm
not on earth I wasn't killed when I was
put in this hell they gave me a nice
selling or making me do tests on people
they're trying to make some type of
serum but they have all failed so far I
was a doctor on earth but I never did
stuff like this the screams are killing
me
I hate myself for being a coward not
fighting back and for what I have done
did he does peeing all these people
forgive me god I think I'm gonna give
myself the serum I know will kill me but
I have sinned and I need to suffer
consequences for what I've done to these
poor people that were dragged from their
homes during the night I gave myself a
serum it's just a matter of time now
I'll be going home or to hell I haven't
died yet
it seems the serum was changed the last
time I used it on someone I think it may
be working no God I don't know what will
happen to me but I phone suddenly feel
stronger I started wanting blood so I
killed two prisoners I just couldn't
help it I'm going to be one of them
forever and wander these halls the halls
of this hell but I won't tell them I
made the serum because it's the only
good thing I can do before I die tell
them how or what is this you are you
dead what's going on I need to fix the
ladder
don't know how I do that all right
anyway I'm out of time for this episode
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always we'll see you oh no wait
wait a minute wait a minute the game
crashed my timers off we still got a
minute ah do everything I can in a
minute good in a minute
I like how that said what the hell okay
good for padlocks alrighty then we still
got a minute oh they do oh it sounded
like a bad moose man oh so place is
gonna collapse going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you get out here oh ah yeah here go
what you what is that [ __ ] Oh
clunk ah it broke ins ha
oh I should have stopped oh I actually
don't have to carry on thank you very
much because that's all the time I have
for this episode thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in next part bye bye